karl weiss bonsoir doctoresse surprise
je parlais un médecin de l'om est ce ce
midi qui me disait la difficulté en
europe puis chez vous canada par exemple
c'est de faire comprendre aux gens que
vous ça diminue ça ralentit on le voit
mais sur l'échelle internationale
ça augmente cette pandémie et il ya
quelques jours on a eu la journée où il
ya eu le plus de nouveaux cas du par
rapport au tout début je fais entente
est très court
un petit extrait du docteur ce au sein
de janet convient tout je pense que vous
avez bien résumé la situation globale
par les témoins d'insister sur certains
aspects c'est vrai que le monde a
tendance à croire que les puits délit en
train de baisser compte tenu de ce qu'on
a vu en europe de l'est sous les cadres
devenus de plus en plus sur la date doit
balmain il a fallu deux semaines peut
passer de 6 millions de cas rapportés à
8 millions de cardan c'est une évolution
très rapide
le treize jeunes passé on a eu le plus
grand mal de cas rapportés un jour ça
veut dire plus de 140 nique et le brésil
aux états unis et doyen de sont
aujourd'hui les tropiques ont rapporté
le plus de cas tant qu'il ya quelque
chose un peu décourageant d'intervalle
ce qu'on attend ça malgré tout ça manque
partout il faudrait pas dire
décourageons pas ce que c'était attendu
alors je pense que si les gens pensent
qu'une pandémie
c'était un événement local ise de 12
semaines où tout le monde a été confiné
et que là on a sorti le slogan ça va
bien aller que tout est fini c'est pas
du tout ça la réalité une pandémie c'est
une épidémie à l'échelle planétaire avec
des systèmes de santé différent des
besoins différents des capacités
différentes des populations différentes
quand on vous parle du brésil avec plus
de 200 millions d'habitants ou de l'inde
avec un milliard trois cents millions
d'habitants dans des conditions parfois
qui sont pas très bonnes
la même chose avec l'afrique la même
chose avec de nombreux pays du moyen
orient
sans compter tous les pays où on ne
comptabilise pas les cas alors on peut
s'imaginer qu'il ya encore énormément
clients sur la planète ne pour ceux qui
rient cela et qui peut donc se propager
très rapidement
alors quand on dit par exemple on a à
peu près on va dire faire un chiffre
grosso modo à peu près 8 9 millions de
cas actuellement qui ont été confirmés
sur la planète
on sait que ça ne représente que ou plus
dans le meilleur des cas 10 % des vrais
cardon qui à peu près 80 90 millions de
personnes sur cette planète qui ont déjà
été infectées par le corona virus et 90
millions ça paraît beaucoup mais en
proportion en pourcentage on est en bas
de 10% à peu près donc
on est simplement bas de 10 % de la
planète ça veut dire qu'il ya encore
plus de 90% des gens qui habitent cette
terre ils n'ont pas été affectés par le
coran navires us
donc c'est un peu normal qu'on soit
encore pris avec ce genre de chiffres
l'ain d'où l'importance de penser que
retourner à une vie près coronavirus
bientôt c'est illusoire et c'est même
dangereux sur certains aspects parce que
tant qu'il y aura des pays où le taux
d'infection augmenté mais même s'il
tourne avec d'infection n'augmentait pas
tant que rodez pays affligée avec deco
nombreux et la possibilité que le virus
revient dans les endroits où si beaucoup
plus calme et hélas oui tout à fait et
puis même au québec il faut pas se
leurrer on est en train de diminuer
notre nombre de cas mais on a eu un
bilan extrêmement négatif et qui a été
un des pires du monde on va dire
développer pour ne pas dire le pire est
donc c'est sûr que si à partir d'un
moment donné on ne suivait pas des
consignes strictes et on en revenait à
une espèce de déconfinement total lâché
complètement les mesures de précaution
on commencerait à avoir d' un nombre de
cas qui va augmenter
et même si sa peine chez des jeunes d où
des gens relativement en bonne santé
éventuellement ça va faire tache d'huile
et ça va continuer à toucher d'autres
personnes il faut pas non plus oublier
que chaque partie du monde est observé
par les autres et que à partir du moment
où on était un mauvais élèves on peut
aussi fermer notre les frontières des
autres par rapport à nous donc ça s'il
faut pas l'oublier les gens par exemple
sont dans un mode festif estival
certains pensent peut-être à dire
ouverts
j'allais en vacances c'est très beau
tout ça mais si on a une situation qui
n'est pas contrôlée les gens n'allaient
pas s' à venir nous voir arriver chez
eux donc vous et je le sens depuis
plusieurs semaines vous cette parce que
je vous ai souvent posé la question dr
20 cette dichotomie où cette séparation
que l'on fait entre ce qui se passe dans
les résidences pour personnes âgées
d'une part où c'est épouvantable et la
transmission communautaire dans la leur
est la population qui ne peut pas élever
dans certains cas qui n'existe pas dans
certaines régions vous ça parce que ça
vous agace mais vous dites attention il
faut faire attention on n'est pas
prémuni ça va pas et qu'on n'est pas
dans une résidence de personnes âgées
que tout va bien parce qu'on est con et
prémunir
alors il faut certainement pas dire au
québec si on n'avait pas eu des
personnes âgées on aurait bien fait
d'autant plus que je trouve d'abord que
c'est très dommage de dire que quand on
arrive plus de 5000 morts chez les
personnes âgées
les gens qui ont bâti le québec l'ont
construit le quai benghazi on court
beaucoup de dire finalement si on
n'avait pas eu ces gens là on aurait
bien fait on a on n'a pas bien fait puis
il ya des pays où les personnes âgées
qui était dans les chu celle des sons
ont été transférés à l'hôpital sont
décédées à l'hôpital et donc on a
considéré s'attendent était lié donc on
peut beaucoup joué sur la définition de
de kiêu et qui a été transporté ou le
fait est que ces personnes âgées si vous
vous rappelez du début d'épidémie
on a eu des travailleurs de la santé qui
ont été probablement des chevaux de
troie asymptomatiques ou peu malade qui
sont allés travailler nos pensées ch et
celle des cons a laissé un lina ch et
celle des à l'autre on n'a pas confiner
ces travailleurs de la santé ils mentent
et de l'équipement de façon drastique
est dramatique et tout ça mis ensemble
on a mis le on a mis un peu le feu aux
poudres des chsct mai initialement les
clous de la pandémie au québec n'a pas
commencé dans les maisons de retraite
elle a commencé chez des québécois qui
sont venus de l'extérieur à la commande
chez ceux des visiteurs
ils sont arrivés au canada avec des
frontières qui était ouvert elle a
commencé chez des travailleurs de la
santé qui était symptomatique ou pas et
qui sont allés travailler et donc c'est
à partir de là
on a propagé cet aspect là il faut pas
non plus oublier qu'on a beaucoup de
gens qui ont été malades et qu'on n'a
pas testé parce qu'on n'avait pas la
capacité de les tester
et comme il n'était pas trop malade et
on ne les hospitaliser pas ces gens là
auraient testé positif de toutes les
façons alors comme je vous dis qu'on n'a
probablement eu seulement 10% des vrais
cas infectés au québec qui ont été
testées les autres ont pas été trop
malade ou pas ces malades pour être
testés dont et ils ont quand même été
malade et la baisse des inscrits
alisation quand même marqué au québec
vous en êtes où dans votre réflexion là
dessus
alors non c'est clair qu'on est temps on
a fini notre première vague première
vague le gros est en arrière de nous
qu'on a réussi à passer au travers on
l'a payé un prix extrêmement élevé et
donc la question maintenant c'est
qu'elles je dirai quelle question
quelles règles quelles leçons tirer de
tout ça pour se préparer à une
éventuelle seconde vague parce que ce
qu'on sait c'est que vous voyez qu'on
sera pas capable de contenir la plongée
de 19 à l'échelle planétaire
vous avez des gens qui vous disent y ait
des pays dans le monde où ça va pas très
bien donc c'est vrai que ça va continuer
le virus n'a pas disparu deuxièmement il
ya très peu de gens au québec on va dire
dans le meilleur des cas 8 9% de la
population qui ont été infectés donc les
autres sont encore des clients
potentiels
troisièmement on ne retournera pas un
confinement aussi sévère qu'on a eues
durant la première balle c'est clair
qu'on ne sera pas complètement paralysé
les l'impact économique social est
beaucoup trop grand donc on va avoir des
gens qui vont retourner à l'école
c'est très bien on va avoir des gens
peuvent entraîner travailler on va avoir
des gens qui vont être dans un système
plus ouvert on va retourner à les
activités économiques plus ouvert donc
tous à se serrer c'est impensable pour
avoir plus de cas dr weill et vous
répéter qu'il faudrait imposer le masque
en public
oui alors ça fait très longtemps on peut
rentrer encore une fois sur la
sémantique vous avez lu que la
californie
en plus de nombreux états américains
viennent de faire exactement la même
chose quand on parle d'un position ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut donner des
amendes aux gens valeurs qui ne
porteront pas de masque c'est à dire
qu'il ya un aspect éducatif
il ya un aspect de distribution des
masques et un aspect de fournir des
as tu mais c'est très clair que plus que
réellement il faut qu'on fasse le
progrès très rapides et qu'on arrête de
tourner en rond autour du pot en disant
que le masque oui peut-être sa part une
certaine utilité
les études s'accumulent et les données
sacré bien c'est tout reconnaître
d'intervalle je vous remercie je veux
vous reparler avant que je disparaisse
des ondes la semaine prochaine donc
donnons nous rendez vous mardi c'est on
va pouvoir s'écrire comme d'habitude
alors merci mais on se dira pas a dit
aujourd'hui rose est radieux notre foi
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup d'acteurs
valls salue